hi
it is time for drew's news your daily
cat nap in the warm sun puddle of good
news
and with me at the desk is my funky
little news kitten rossi rasmus yeah
meow
hi everybody
okay first up we love digging into the
latest terms and trends in dating and
we've got a new one for you for the new
year the independent reports dating apps
say power pda is officially a thing
and it's not just for the megan foxes
and machine gun kelly's of the world
seventy percent of daters globally say
they're more open to public a smoochin
rusty thoughts
listen i you know who i don't like the
people who say get a room you know why
because you go get a room and sit by
yourself and be lonely
i think
we are
we are so lucky if you have love in your
life you know to to show it and you
remember those first few months of a
relationship where you just can't get
enough like if people are in that zone
don't rain on their parade don't let
them have that we need more love in the
world don't you think
[Applause]
get it i'm not going to judge you you
totally turned me around for real i i
was going to represent the town like
grumps
and be like
just
stop it like with the licking right by
my face yes don't and all of a sudden
i'm listening to you and going yeah
yeah because you remember remember that
feeling you know
right back there it is there it is
and i used to be the biggest make-out
bandit i used to like walk into places
and be like you
and just smack them with kisses really
i did
um
so just hearing you like about love in
the world and being happy for people and
how like tedious the getter room
naysayers are i'm with you i'm back i'm
in yeah fine
maybe i'll do it too again i'm very
persuasive you know you really are you
lit my fire right yeah well i've seen
every episode of the good wife so i'm
basically a lawyer all right um next up
the average person checks their phone
262 times a day think about that and you
know you do it and now fox news reports
a new study found that 90 of people
admit to using their phone on the toilet
that's okay
i'm looking at everyone in the audience
now okay
and 53 of those people say they've used
their phones and sat there until their
legs and butt fell asleep
[Applause]
which i couldn't stop laughing when i
read this because
you know you've done it right
where then you're you're saying and you
you realize like oh my god now you have
to like wiggle your legs until the
tingling stops before you even i'm just
like wash your hands just wash your
hands sound of hands though who has used
the telephone on the old lou
i mean
i love it wait
there's a woman who is shaking her head
i want to know do you really
it just happens to be my one rule and i
will not give in
oh my god i don't know why it's my one
thing i can't bring it in there
and what is your name nicole
gosh nicole yeah
um combined with my fear of possibly
dropping in the toilet because i am a
little clumsy so i just go with it i can
i can't even
imagine not having the phone i mean i
will like hold it to charge the phone so
i can use it to go you know it's like
to me it's as important as having a
toilet there
just having the phone there
well apparently ninety percent of the
world agrees with yeah and eight more
percent are lying to us because i know
98 of people do this i agree when i
heard there was a 10
missing i was like you know what nicole
nicole
congratulations nicole
better than us
well next up we've got a new study on
dog brains for anyone who loves to talk
to their pooch scientists say that for
the most part dogs really rely on
context of your tone of voice and
gestures to understand what you're
saying you have three little dogs i do
have three dogs and i believe this they
are so smart they know what i'm saying
all the time
well and you just gestured oh i did do
that didn't i so maybe that helps well
the wall street journal reports that a
new study found dogs can actually
understand the boundaries between
separate words and they can hear a word
and mentally compute
what word is likely to come next this is
something that an eight-month-old human
baby starts to do so if you say to your
dog
do you want a blank
he might have a guess or a real big wish
for what word you're going to say next i
can tell you with douglas and lucy i'm
like
dude
i get really alpha on the dog you do oh
look at your dog because you have to you
do you have to be the pack leader drew
you do i am a pack leader i was a single
mother with two dogs and i i raised them
in california off the leash and i'm like
i am
and then i'm really loving and
affectionate but don't mess around yeah
i i'm not i let the dogs walk all over
me no this is not look at my three these
are my three chihuahuas oh my gosh and
they are so sweet but super smart i
think because i raised them you know so
i can even
like when it's five o'clock and i walk
towards the kitchen they're like we know
what you're doing we know
all right well um for all the dogs uh
watching we've got a new story for you
uh all those they're cause they're
paying attention to what we're saying
uh all those good healthy habits we
wanna develop you know we're all working
hard you try to do it but sometimes you
fail well huffington post reports habit
stacking listen to that habit stacking
is a way you can try to sneak good
self-care habits into your everyday
routine and it works very simply you
just attach a good new habit to an
existing habit you already do so for
like for example once you brush your
teeth
do 10 squats every time after you walk
your dog you come home you drink a big
glass of water makes sense right
like for me i like to multitask so every
time i watch 90 day fiance and there's a
commercial i go fill up my pinot grigio
two at the same time
easy
easy would you ever try this
no
well yes i mean i don't know god you
know just another thing i can feel like
crap about that like
the teeth brushing isn't enough i didn't
do 10 squats
and here i am sucking down caffeine when
i know i should be hydrating with water
it's never enough but i do like the term
habit stacking like i've never heard
that before but i'm a lured to it it
doesn't turn me off it's a good term so
what's something you do every single day
i brush my teeth i let's start there
okay so you brush your teeth so there's
what's something you'd like to be doing
more of
that's good for you
i need to drink more water always i'm i
i
i yeah okay all right so then how about
every time you brush your teeth you just
commit to drinking eight ounces of water
all right
i'm gonna talk to you like a dog right
now you better drink water
we'll be right back with more cruise
news
[Music]
you